[Music]
though the expanded dune universe by
Brian Herbert and Kevin J Anderson
offers some contradicting dates and
accounts to the Dune encyclopedia the
encyclopedia provides the most
comprehensive timeline of the Dune
universe though in the original Frank
Herbert doom books earth is lost in the
midst of time the encyclopedia offers
states stretching all the way from
humanity's early beginnings on earth to
a few thousand years after the death of
the god emperor Leto ii up until the in
universe publication of the encyclopedia
itself in 1540 AG the encyclopedia dates
the earliest civilizations on earth or
tera as somewhere around 19,000 BG this
is not an exact date because it was far
too long ago to measure precisely this
would be around to 800 BC using
real-world measurements of time the Dune
encyclopedia dates the rise and fall of
the Roman Empire as somewhere in between
16400 B G and 16,000 B G this is
somewhat relevant because the Atreides
can trace their ancestry back to Rome
1900 standard years later in 14100 the
colonization of the solar system begins
it was known as the little diaspora the
word diaspora refers to a scattered
population the word in the real world is
most commonly associated with the jewish
expulsion from israel which was called
the jewish diaspora over the course of
the next 500 standard years the
population of earth decreased by
approximately 2,000 percent one of the
first planets colonized during the
Diaspora was Cerys and when earth was
struck by an asteroid in 13 402 b g
series became the imperial capital 400
years later terror was receded and
declared a natural park by the current
reigning emperor
by 12200 BG humanity had expanded to ten
more interstellar colonies ruled by a
single emperor though communication
between worlds was difficult in those
times a millennia later humanity had
entered what was known as the Empire of
a thousand worlds this may have
literally referred to a thousand planets
however it is also possible that it
merely referred to a large number of
planets in this time imperial power was
far too sparse to claim supremacy over
the entire interstellar confederation it
was an empire only in name by eleven 105
B G a rebellion had destroyed the seat
of imperial power on the planet Ceres
this was the beginning of what the
encyclopaedia calls the Age of
pretenders eventually many smaller
empires would emerge and many Emperor's
during the great Dark Ages which was
also known as the age of ten thousand in
brewer's this age would last nearly 4000
years seeing the thinker's rebellion of
7600 b gene and the birth of Ibrahim von
Holtzman in seventy-five 93 BG who the
Encyclopedia credits as the discoverer
of the holtzman effect the dark ages
ended when Holtzman demonstrated the
Holtzman effect and revealed his
discoveries the Holtzman effect provided
a means of instant communication between
worlds his theories would also lead to
the invention of the Holtzman Drive
would provide it faster than light space
travel for the next 2500 standard years
after the discovery of the Holtzman
effect the Wars of reunification were
waged until finally latus lost the great
United mankind into a single Empire
starting what was called the first
Golden Age sometime during this age sand
trout were first brought to the men wet
planet Arrakis the years 1800 BG through
200 BG saw the rise and fall of the
second Golden Age and the beginning of
the but Larian jihad when a crusade was
led against all thinking machines in the
Imperium by 108 BG the last thinking
machine was destroyed
in 88 BG during the Battle of Corinne
sardick our soldier Demetrios Atreides
assumed command of the vessel luta after
the senior officers had all perished
because of his actions here he was named
Baron of the planet Tantalus by Emperor
Shu set the first pedasi emperor whose
house would later change its name from
Causton to Kirino after the planet
quarantine in 84 BG the abilities of the
spice melange to aid in space travel was
discovered in 5bg chome company is
founded and by the Year Zero the
Imperial seat the spacing guild and
chome company which contained the lands
rad the Great Houses of the Imperium
joined together to form the Imperium as
we know it to be every year after this
contains the epic AG meaning after guild
as opposed to BG meaning before guilt
over the next 10,000 years nearly 300
Emperor's would sit the Imperial seat
the Year 1234 saw the formation of the
order of mint at by Gilbert of Alban a
famous philosopher and logician it began
on the planet Septimus and in 1244 the
order of mint had moved to the planet
clay lacks in 3367 AG the Empire saw the
first instance of a war of assassins
when house our Conan feuded with house
party a war of assassins his warfare of
a limited nature which involved the use
of professional assassins among rival
and Great Houses of the landsraad and
6,600 AG as in suni sayyidina on the
planet rossik discovered a plant which
had properties which allowed it to
unlock in her lives she becomes the
first wild Reverend Mother by 71 93 all
of the Zen Sunni Wanderers who had later
become the Fremen had arrived on Arrakis
in 86 77 AG Paulus Atreides the
sixteenth moved his entire family from
the planet Gallatin to the Paradise
world of Caledon which was granted to
the House by Emperor Elle
viii in 101 40 AG late to a trade is the
first is born and in 101 56 AG Shaddam
the forth becomes emperor of the
Imperium Paul Atreides was born in 101
75 AG and in the year 100 198 G House
Atreides gained the fiefdom over the
planet Arrakis Oh some known as doom by
101 93 AG Hall Atreides had gained
control of the Imperium through his
control of the spice melange by 101 96
AG the jihad had begun Paul's Freeman
spread throughout the galaxy the Freeman
who had once fled subjugation
now oppressed billions and 102 19 AG the
reign of the God Emperor later ii began
he ruled for 3,500 years and died in the
year 13 724 AG according to the
encyclopedia but 13 728 AG according to
the original saga in 14 702 AG what was
thought to be the first evidence of
non-human biological intelligent
life-forms was discovered on the planet
Crumpton they had detected ruins on the
planet surface by use of a low altitude
satellite a ground crew was dispatched
but they discovered no remaining
intelligent life the spacing guild was
certain that no human had ever set foot
on the planet beforehand and the ruins
were thought to be between three and
five thousand years old later however
the idea of alien intelligence was
debunked when it became clear that this
was more likely a no room created by
late to the second though they still had
no idea why or when he built it in 15200
AG some of those who fled the famine
times into the scattering after the
death of the worm God Emperor began to
return to the old Empire among them were
the honored ma trace in the year 15 525
the god emperors journals are discovered
he had recorded them his record of his
life and his accounts of his inner lives
unruhe Dooley and crystals hidden on
Arrakis he had left them there to be
discovered by humanity at a future date
the full timeline of the Dune universe
according to the encyclopedia spans over
roughly thirty four thousand years by
the end of it all humanity has spread to
the very furthest reaches of space
no single human could ever catalog all
of humanity at this point and no one can
say what each of their individual
experiences might entail if you enjoyed
this video please consider supporting
this channel on patreon link in the
description I'd like to take this time
to thank some of my very best patrons
mostly Trini girl and Cher Valentine my
top patrons and also Ivan slaughter
claudia young sean Lorenzen vanessa
green the ghost of raymond red beard
robbing laundry Mara Chris Zoe Zhang
Dominique Maldonado
Joe Iverson and Cara Jane thank you all
so much
[Music]
you